All right, it's time for Drew's News.
Your news Zen garden,
where we slowly rake the sands of the good news.
Ooh.
And with me at the desk
is a man who helps me keep calm and carry on every day,
Ross Mathews.
Hi everybody, hi.
(audience cheers)
Look at this crowd.
(audience applauds)
Cute.
Hi, poca.
Okay, first up, I don't know about you,
but I love seeing inside people's homes.
Totally.
I am a real creeper creature,
and especially, when it comes to design,
I mean, that is my happy place.
So Architectural Digest does these home tours with people
and Buzzfeed reports that actress,
Ashley Tisdale just did one.
And Ms. Tisdale caused a real Tisdale tizzy
over this moment.
So here's the moment.
This is what got got everybody's panties in a wad.
Everybody's talking about it.
These bookshelves, I have to be honest
were not actually, did not have books in it,
like a couple days ago.
I had my husband go to a bookstore and I was like,
(laughing) "You need to get 400 books".
(audience laughs)
So people had a field day on Twitter.
Ashley took it in stride.
She tweeted back that some of the books were, in fact, hers
and she only did what any interior designer would have done,
but people got angry about this.
Yeah.
I...
I know, and I'm not gonna read Ashley Tisdale for filth
just like she didn't read any of those books, okay.
No judgment to you.
And you know what I think?
I have a lot of books in my house.
I haven't read any of 'em.
My fiance, Wellington, he's read 'em all.
I'm like, "Can you tell me about 'em
or just tell me when they make it into a movie", right?
(audience laughs)
'Cause I don't have time.
Are you reading all the books in your house?
I mean, Ms. Tisdale took the words out of my mouth.
I was literally going to go into interior design
before this show came.
I love interior design.
I study it.
This is what an interior designer would do.
This happens in magazines and things all the time.
How dare people rip this girl apart
for something so asinine!
Mm-hm, like preach, Drew Barrymore, preach.
Leave her alone.
Miss Tisdale, I'm with you, I've got your back,
and thank you for contributing to a bookstore
and putting money in their coffers, which they need.
You're just doing the same thing
(audience applauds)
that other people do
and you don't need to be ripped for it.
And everyone who ripped her, get a life.
I can't handle this.
Oh, okay.
Makes me so mad.
Drew has spoken everyone.
You hear that?
She's got your back, Ashley.
She got me way too heated.
Yeah, you did.
All right, next up, I have a question for you, Drew.
Okay, do you wear shoes in your house?
Yeah, I do.
(chuckles) I knew you did.
Well, the shoe inside the house debate is not news
but now, the blog, Scary Mommy reports,
scientists have officially weighed in
and they say don't you dare walk around your house
in your dirty, filthy shoes,
'cause they are gross.
And scientists say your disgusting shoes are responsible
for one third of the filth in your home.
Yeah, they track in bacteria, microorganism,
toxins, chemicals,
(audience groans)
doggy doo doo,
all that stuff all gets on your floor
and floats into the air particles.
And so you are literally breathing in
your dirty shoe dirt, Drew.
(audience groans)
Are you gonna change?
No
(audience laughs)
(sighs) I don't know.
Again, this kind of goes into like the acai bowls
and the microbes and the whole thing.
I'm just like, you know what?
Germs help build up immunity.
I love when I'm in a dirty public bathroom
and I'm standing there and I think,
"I know you'll be on my bedroom carpet later."
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
But like, I don't care.
By the way, you know what the dirtiest thing is,
according to a lot of studies?
What?
Money.
Really?
Yes.
That is worse than toilet, you know, handles.
Really, well, guess what, everyone?
You can bring your money in my house
but leave your shoes on the porch, okay.
(audience laughs)
Not happening.
(audience applauds)
It's just coming from everywhere.
Blugh.
It's coming from everywhere.
It's hard.
I'm not uptight about stuff like that.
Mm.
I'm more offended that people
ripped this girl for buying books, you know?
That, I'm like, "Really?"
Why, in this tender world right now,
do you have to make someone feel bad
for something like that?
And then just wear the shoes?
I don't know.
I'm very positive,
but this is the kind of stuff where I'm just like, no.
Leave your shoes on and leave Ashley Tisdale alone.
Understood.
Everyone got it?
Good.
But wait.
I would love to-
(audience applauds)
Those are the rules.
I'd love to know how many people here,
because it is really a thing.
And it's like, there are cultural things.
There are people who really are
passionate about cleanliness.
How many people here do take their shoes off at their house?
(audience whoops and claps)
Yeah.
A lot of people, Kyle, Kyle.
Ecclesiastically.
May I ask you why?
And I'd like to learn from you,
because I am not closed minded about this.
I just am too lazy, I think.
That's my problem.
There, yeah.
Well, it's a combination of two things.
Okay.
One, the germs,
as Ross said.
Uh-huh.
And the other is we vacation in Hawaii
and there's tradition everyone takes their shoes off.
So we bring that tradition back to New York.
Oh that's cute.
Thank you.
Oh.
I went to Hawaii once and got laid.
I'd like to bring that tradition.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
(bright theme music)